funny as it might have been plants vs.
zombies garden warfare was no joke
though it retained the offbeat yet
disarming humor that helps make the
original tower defense game such a
massive multi-platform hit garden
workers successfully spun the universe
into an impressively rich and robust
third-person shooter so as you might
expect plants vs. zombies garden warfare
2 expands its predecessors winning
formula by adding brand new characters
fleshing out fan favorite modes and
introducing a wealth of new features
from cute rookie surprises to an active
engaging hub world as before you take
control of either the plants or the
zombies as you battle for backyard
supremacy in a variety of competitive
and cooperative multiplayer events both
sides still offer the same selection of
highly distinctive playable characters
that fill various strategic roles you'll
find tanks diapers heavy gunners
artillery units basically everything
you'd expect to find in a deep
class-based tactical shooter just with
more floppy flower petals and
gap-toothed undead grins with the advent
of garden warfare 2 each side is set to
grow by three characters plants get
citron rose and kernel corn while
zombies get input captain dead beard and
super brains in both cases these new
character types fill gaps in the roster
which should create both a better
balance and greater diversity Rose for
example is a medic type who does best
buffing her teammates or hindering her
opponents from behind the frontlines
super brains in the other hand is
designed to deliver devastating melee
attacks after charging headlong into
danger making him a kamikaze unit if
you're not careful impressively not only
can you deck out all 14 total characters
and a huge array of unlockable cosmetic
accessories every character has at least
5 variant forms Chomper becomes Yeti
Chomper peashooter becomes Rock PE foot
soldier becomes Scooby soldier and so on
unlike the accessories these variant
forms actually affect the way these
characters play offering brand new basic
attacks special abilities and more ap
Minh has a Mass Effect themed n7 mech
suit variant that allows him to jetpack
around the mat for a limited time it
seems the only way to unlock these
alternate forms is to find them in a
mystery card pack purchased with in-game
currency but this gradual accumulation
of new characters should provide a
constantly expanding pool of new
gameplay options even if it's random
in addition to the six new characters
and their accompanying variants garden
warfare 2 also delivers new ways to play
such as the previously announced
playable hub world and solo side
missions that take place in their own
discrete areas in the garden ops board
mode for example you can now spawn AI
allies and swap between them on the fly
rather than forcing three actual friends
to join you for co-op those foot screen
is now an option
most importantly though garden worker 2
still features a full suite of
competitive multiplayer options with
maps that support up to 24 players and
modes that no longer require plants to
be full-time defenders while zombies
constantly invade most impressive among
the options I saw during a controlled
hands-on session in December with
gardens and graveyards an objective
based competitive sprint in the style of
battlefields rush mode that forces both
teams to dash from map to map through a
history themed amusement park win enough
encounters and your team gets a chance
to storm the other team stronghold in
the final area each zone offered
something completely different
whether it was gunfights in low gravity
or a resource gathering minigame that
challenged both teams to guide giant
orbs into the opposing team's goal and
crucially I died a whole lot which
actually gave me a chance to respawn as
a huge number of different characters
while I found some to be more useful and
familiar than others I was constantly
impressed by the inventiveness of each
class I also never felt helpless or
outmatched regardless of who I picked at
first glance imps z7 mech suit seems
unstoppable but with a little
experimentation I eventually figured out
which classes could shut them down
effectively with such an expansive and
varied collection of content along with
some tight accessible shooting mechanics
driving the hold experience garden
warfare to surprise me it's silly
exterior hides a genuinely fun
functional and thoughtful shooter of
course you can find all this out for
yourself when the beta goes live
tomorrow January 14
you